destiny lachey has died she was 30 years
old no cause of death is known at this
time i decided hey i look like a woman
maybe i should try on wigs
and so one day i tried on certain wigs
and makeup
and i was like i'm so beautiful destiny
was the first transgender person to be
chronicled on my 600 pound life the
reality star's brother wayne compton
shared news of her death on tuesday
wayne posted these photos of destiny to
facebook writing in part quote i accept
you for who you are and i'm sorry you
felt so alone
at this rate i give myself a couple
months
and that's not the future i should be
facing
before i've hardly even had a chance to
live my life
tlc the network behind my 600 pound life
released a statement to et how deep the
sympathies go out to destiny's family
and loved ones at this difficult time
destiny appeared on season seven of the
reality series in 2019. every single day
of my life it's hard
[Music]
because
every day i feel like i'm dying
and every day i'm becoming more and more
helpless
you're not going to be in melbourne for
much longer with where you out and once
you become better then your health is
gonna start to decline rapidly at that
point so this is your chance to change
that if you want got it yes sir i feel
like i'm ready
in her episode destiny got candid about
her struggles with depression and how it
impacted her weight loss journey and i
can't believe this is my life now
where i just lay here all day and wait
for food
and i don't see any of my family and
friends unless they come to see me
i feel like all i'm constantly doing is
just trying to escape all my depression
and pain at this point
and food is the only thing i have to
turn to to do that
i can feel it killing me
destiny eventually lost over 500 pounds
which she documented on social media